あのなんかこう あの暴走に対する非道とかっていうふうなものに対して
こう それは非常にまずいからやめた方がいいというのを説得するようなシチュエーションにおいて
自分がうまく論理展開ができないけども
これは絶対やめさせた方がいいっていう場合は
どういう順番でいけば簡単です
犬を侮辱していいんですか？それよくないでしょ
自分飼ってる猫を侮辱したらいいんですか？だったら家に一緒に住んでる人々を侮辱するのも悪いでしょ
学校の先生侮辱するのも悪いでしょ
会社の社長を侮辱するのも悪いでしょ
どんどん偉く行けば行くほど
それの過程なんです  でも
その因果法則に対する理解が
要するに 自分がいいことしてるのにいい結果は出ないというふうに確信している
なんかそういう  それは非科学的でしょう
いいことをするならば
いい結果が出るに決まっている
結果が悪ければ もう一度考え直すことでしょうに
例えば薬を飲んだら病気が治るとすごいしっかりしている
自分がなんかパクパクと飲んでも病気が治ってないんだったら
プラセボを飲んでる可能性もあるでしょうに
だからいいことをしているならば
いい結果になってるはずなんですけど
私にはなってないんだよというならば
あんた本当にやってることいいことでしょうかと
だから自分は体感的に間違いないと思っている
だからあなたはやってないから
そういうふうに思うだけなんだというふうに言っても
それを理解しないということに関して
だからそれも押し付けですからね
自分なんです でもでも
これは絶対押し付けても嘘じゃないから
もう間違いないと思っている
だからといって押し付けはもうそれはうまくいかない
お釈迦様さえも押し付けじゃなかったんだから
なんであんたにできるんですかね
押し付けはよく あの 4つも良くない
ブッダさえも押し付けはしてないんですよ
押し付けた気持ち自体はもうかなり感情なんですよ
まあどちらかというと怒りなんですよ
嫌だから あの考え方っていうね
自分にとって嫌なんです
本人の考え方を尊重しなきゃ
それでニコニコ 例えば子供と私言ったでしょ
それで子供たちがなんかうるさくて
もうガチャガチャものを壊す
勉強もしないわね それで黙ってろ
落ち着けとか何とか言ったっても
やってくる 押し付けですよ
それで私は君は本当に賢くていい子だと思っていたんだけどと言って
それでストップするんですよ
押し付けないんですよ
すごい悪口を言うと もう君が無茶可愛いと思っていたんだけど
私はとかね そういうふらえるますよ
相手が きちんとやってる悪いことをやめてくれる
押し付けじゃないんです
だから人は自分の意見が正しいと思ってるんですよ
こんなのはもうしょうがないでしょうに
だからあなた方の仕事はそれ理解すること
初めから たとえ明らかに変な考え方であろうとも
それは持っている人にとっては変じゃないんです
本人にとっては それこそもうまとめなまとめなすごい考え方なんです
だからそこは知ったところから
いかないと 押し付けは決してしないこと
話し方の流れ言ったでしょうね
結論は相手が出すんであって
自分が出すものじゃないんです
話し方の場合は だから結構ただ単にできませんよ
だからその相手を説得しようというぐらいの慈しみの心があれば
そういう細かく細かくやっていくことは可能かもしれないです
そうじゃないけども 相手が明らかに爆弾の信管ハンマー振り上げているような状態は
ちょっとそこはやめといた方がいいんじゃないかというぐらいの気持ちで説得しようっていうのが
相手に慈しみがないんだよ
放っておけばいいんじゃないんですかね
でもその ないというわけじゃないけども
なんかひどいことにはならん方がいいんじゃないかというぐらいの気持ちっていうのは中途半端だよ
まあ例えばこう 酒を飲むなというのは
お釈迦様が言ったことだというふうに自分が言っても
そんなのはお釈迦様は人
単なる人じゃないかというスタンスで言われたりすると
こちらはそういうふうな視点では思っていてほしいなと
それは危険なので言いたいんだけども
でもそれは改めさせるだけの慈しみでもって
純粋に解いていくほどには思わないという
なんかこう  だから 例えばその具体的なことを言うと
私の具体的な答えが出ますよ
お釈迦様はただの何でしたっけ？ ただのある人が言っただけではない
ただのある人 あなたもただのある人でしょ
でもあなたが言ってることは私さえも認めてないんですけど
でも ただのある人が言ってることは
2600年もみんな信じてしっかりやってますよと
ただのある人なんですけど
あなたお野菜もあんた言うことがいけないんだよ
それだけでしょうに データでしょうに
だからデータでいけますよ
それも相手に押し付けること全くない
今 私の今シミュレーションで言ったことで全然押し付けてない
相手の意見は取っているんです
これ反対意見ですよ 小坂さん
ただの人間だけど 君も本人そういう立場で言ってるでしょうに
あの人もただの人間 俺も私もただの人間という形でしょ
はい その通りです というところでいくんです
だから最初から反対してないんだけど
結局最後にやられるんです
だからデータが必要なんですよ
並び替えも
サッビーティーイワンジャントゥサッブローグーイナッストゥマーテーバワットアンタラーヨースキーディーガーユコーバヴァーバウトゥサッブマンガランラッカント
ゥサッブディベタサッブブッダヌーバヴェーナサッブダンマーヌーバヴェーナサッブサンガーヌーバヴェーナサダーシュッティバヴァントゥテーアビワダナシーリッサー
ニッチャンヴァッダーパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーヴァッダンキーアーユワンノーシュカンバラン
では どうもありがとうございます